>> Harris: DEMOCRATIC DONORS
ARE SHOWING JOE BIDEN SOME LOVE,
APPARENTLY.
HIS CAMPAIGN SAYS HE RAISED
NEARLY $47 MILLION IN MARCH.
HIS BEST FUND-RAISING MONTH OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
ACTUALLY, MORE THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS HE TOOK
CONTROL OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE PRESUMPTIVE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE TWEETED THIS, IN PART.
"THIS VIRUS HAS CHANGED OUR
CAMPAIGN, BUT IT HAS NOT CHANGE
THE UNWAVERING SUPPORT WE’VE
GOTTEN FROM ALL OF YOU.
TOGETHER, WE ARE GOING TO DEFEAT
TRUMP."
HOWEVER, JOE BIDEN AND HIS
POLITICAL PARTY ARE NEARLY, IN
TOTAL, $187 MILLION BEHIND THE
RNC AND THE PRESIDENT.
WHO YOU MAY KNOW HAS SPENT THE
LAST THREE YEARS STOCKPILING HIS
HUGE WAR CHEST.
AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES" POINTS
OUT, JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
COULD RAISE A MILLION DOLLARS A
DAY BETWEEN NOW AND ELECTION DAY
AND STILL BARELY CATCH UP.
STEVE HILTON, YOU’VE SEEN A
CAMPAIGN OR TWO ACROSS THE POND.
HOW DO YOU CATCH UP WHEN YOU
CAN’T EVEN GET THE BULLY PULPIT
ANYMORE?
EVERY DAY BETWEEN 5:00 AND 7:00
OR SO P.M. EASTERN, YOU CAN’T
GET A WORD IN EDGE WISE,
JOE BIDEN.
>> Steve: YEAH.
WHEN HE DOES TRY TO GET A WORD
IN EDGE WISE, IT’S BEEN
SOMETHING JUMBLED AND INCOHERENT
AND NOT EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANT TO
HEAR IN THE MIDDLE OF SUCH A
SERIOUS SITUATION.
EVEN THE PERFORMANCES HE DOES
MANAGE TO PUT ON HER NOT EXACTLY
REASSURING.
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE’S A LOT OF
COMPLACENCY BUILDING ON THE
DEMOCRAT SIDE THAT JOE BIDEN IS
JUST GOING TO -- SHE’S GOING TO
MAKE A MESS OF THIS CRISIS, HE
WILL OBVIOUSLY BE DEFEATED.
THAT’S COMPLETE WRONG.
I THINK, ACTUALLY, ELECTIONS
TEND TO BE MORE ABOUT THE FUTURE
THAN THE PAST.
THE ARGUMENTS IN NOVEMBER ALL
LINE UP IN FAVOR OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
EVERYTHING HE’S BEEN SAYING FOR
SO LONG ON TRADE, BRINGING
MANUFACTURING HOME, AS WE SAW
EARLIER ON IMMIGRATION, ALL
THESE THINGS -- CHINA, LETS
ARRIVE AT THAT BIG ONE -- SHE’S
ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THOSE BIG ARGUMENTS.
JOE BIDEN, MR. ESTABLISHMENT,
MR. SWAMP, IS ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF THOSE ARGUMENTS.
THAT’S GOING TO BE DECISIVE IN
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW,
MARIE HARF, IN RECENT DAYS WE
BEEN READING MORE AND MORE ABOUT
THE REPORTING THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA HAD A
HEAVIER HAND, IF YOU WILL,
BEHIND-THE-SCENES WHEN
BERNIE SANDERS WAS STILL IN THE
RACE AND KIND OF SMOOTHING THAT
WHOLE THING OUT.
NOW HE’S GETTING READY TO HELP
HE AND THE FORMER FIRST LADY,
MICHELLE OBAMA, REPORTEDLY HELP
JOE BIDEN ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HOW MUCH IS THAT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
>> Marie: I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT COMPLACENT.
I PROMISE, IT MAY SEEM THAT WAY
TO HIM, BUT THE DEMOCRATS I TALK
TO, IT’S ANYTHING BUT
COMPLACENCY.
FOR JOE BIDEN, HE HAD A TRIFECTA
OF REALLY IMPORTANT ENDORSEMENTS
IN THE LAST WEEK.
BARACK OBAMA, AS YOU MENTION,
HARRIS, BRADY SANDERS, WHO
ENDORSED BIDEN MUCH EARLIER THAN
HE ENDORSED HILLARY IN 2016, AND
ELIZABETH WARREN.
WHO STILL HAS A LOT OF SUPPORT
IN MANY PARTS OF THE PARTY.
DEMOCRATS ARE BEHIND OVERALL IN
MONEY, BUT IF MONEY WON
ELECTIONS, HILLARY CLINTON WOULD
BE PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW IT’S NOT DETERMINATIVE.
THE OTHER IMPORTANT MONEY
NUMBERS TO LOOK AT, HARRIS, OR
IN THE HOUSE AND SENATE RACES.
THEY ARE OUT RAISING THEIR
REPUBLICAN OPPONENTS BY LEAPS
AND BOUNDS.
SENATE CANDIDATES LIKE MARK
KELLY, DOING THE SAME THING.
SUSAN COLLINS, GETTING OUTRAISED
RIGHT NOW.
UP IN MAINE, BY SARAH GIDEON.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING THEIR
MONEY TO THE PRESIDENCY, BUT
ALSO TO THE HOUSE AND SENATE
RACES, TO KEEP THE HOUSE AND
HELP WITH THE SENATE.
DEMOCRATS ARE FIRED UP AND THEY
ARE UNIFIED EARLIER THAN THEY
WERE IN 2016.
>> Harris: MARIE, I WOULD
POINT THIS OUT.
THE PLAYING FIELD ISN’T EXACTLY
THE SAME WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT,
"WELL, IF MONEY HAD BEEN THE
ANSWER, HILLARY CLINTON COULD
HAVE WON."
HILLARY CLINTON WAS NOT GOING UP
AGAINST A PANDEMIC AND A
JUGGERNAUT OF NEWS CONFERENCES
EVERY DAY BETWEEN 5:00 AND
7:00 P.M. BY A NUMBER WHOSE
APRESIDENT WHOSE NUMBERS ARE
PRETTY STEADY.
THERE’S A PRETTY TIGHT GRASP
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEM
PICTORIALLY.
THE PRESIDENT IS HOLDING STEADY
THROUGH THIS, THROUGHOUT THIS.
YOU’RE GOING TO NEED SOME CASH,
COLD HARD CASH, TO GET ON THE
AIRWAVES.
AS STEVE POINTED OUT, EVEN
GETTING A WORD IN EDGE WISE IS
HARD.
IT’S HARD TO DO ONLINE.
IT DOESN’T QUITE COMPARE.
>> Marie: HARRIS, IT’S
INTERESTING.
I THINK YOU AND I HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION, MAYBE LAST WEEK ON
"OUTNUMBERED."
YOU’RE RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT HAS
A BULLY PULPIT LIKE NO ONE
ELSE’S, STANDING BEHIND THAT
WHITE HOUSE PODIUM.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE’S ALSO SANG
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE
IMMEDIATELY ENDING UP IN
JOE BIDEN’S ATTACK AD.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO
TALK A LOT.
SOMETIMES IT’S NOT PRECISE, IT’S
NOT ENTIRELY TRUTHFUL, LIKE, "I
DON’T TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY,"
OR, "I DON’T TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY."
IS A DOUBLE-EDGED SWORD, THAT
BULLY PULPIT.
FOR JOE BIDEN, THE CASE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A RETURN TO NORMALCY
NORMALCY.
RIGHT NOW HE MAY BE THE
ESTABLISHMENT BUT HE SEEMS
STABLE.
VOTERS ARE LOOKING FOR STABILITY
RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: I’VE GOT TO TELL
YOU, WHEN STEVE SAYS, "GOSH, ALL
THINGS ABLE TO DO AT THIS
POINT," I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
QUICK LAST WORD.
THE FUTURE IS NOW EVERY DAY,
LATE IN THE AFTERNOON, THE GET
MORE.
HE’S GOT MORE INK, RIGHT NOW, AS
WE SEE IN JOURNALISM, THAN THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Steve: YES.
ALTHOUGH THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS LOVE TO PORTRAY THE
WORST ASPECTS OF WHAT COMES OUT
ON A DAILY BASIS, I THINK WHAT
MORE NEUTRAL MINDED AND
INDEPENDENT AND REASON PEOPLE
SEE THERE IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
REALLY TAKEN CHARGE OF THIS.
HE’S ON TOP OF THE DETAILS.
WHETHER THAT’S VENTILATORS OR
PPE OR WHATEVER ELSE, HE’S
REALLY TAKING CHARGE.
EVERY DAY THEY ARE SEEING THAT.
THAT’S WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE IN A
CRISIS.
AS WE SEE, POTENTIALLY THE LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL,
THROUGH QUESTION TURNS TO,
"WHO’S GOING TO HELP REBUILD
THIS COUNTRY AFTER THE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL DISASTER OF THE
SHUTDOWNS?"
I THINK THERE IS NO CONTEST IN
TERMS OF WHO HAS MORE
CREDIBILITY WITH THOSE CRUCIAL
INDEPENDENT-MINDED VOTERS.
ABOUT WHO IS BEST TO DO THAT.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALL
THE ARGUMENTS IN HIS SIGHT.
>> Harris: WELL, YOU TOO WILL